we spoke with beth wilkinson an attorney
for judge Kavanaugh Nora was with us in
studio 57 before she left for this
morning's interview with Secretary of
State Pompeyo belt Wilkinson good
morning Beth the news this morning is
that USA Today is reporting that dr.
Ford has offered the Senate for people
who corroborate her sexual assault
claims including a friend and her
husband is the evidence mounting against
her client no I wouldn't say that nor as
you know those are statements that were
made relatively recently and sadly this
is an allegation from almost 36 years
ago and there are there was at the time
no report which is understandable but
the first time these allegations came to
light as far as we know from reading the
reports in the media
dr. Blasi told her therapist and told
her husband they announced that there
were notes and that there had been a
lie-detector test test but as I
understand that they did not turn any of
those over to the Senate committee even
though they were requested so the
information that would have shown what
she said at the very first time when she
revealed these allegations have not been
turned over to the Senate wait so you're
saying that that lie-detector test that
they referenced has not the results of
that have not been shared with you or
with the Senate committee as far as I
know last night when the information was
sent in we all received a request from
the Senate to provide any information
and we did not receive from the
documents that they sent in any
information or the results of the
lie-detector test that had been
mentioned in the Washington Post and we
didn't receive the notes from the
therapists that had also been referenced
in the Washington Post and of course
that's very important because apparently
in those notes there's a differing story
about how many people were present at
the party there's no mention of judge
Kavanaugh and so all that information
would be very important to determine you
know whether there's any corroboration
of this allegation and yet eyewitnesses
and friends of Brett Kavanaugh said that
there was excessive drinking while he
was both in high school and in college
in fact his college roommate at Yale
told the New York Times that although
Brett was normally reserved he was
notably a heavy drinker even by the
standards of the time adding he became
aggressive and belligerent
and when he was very drunk does he deny
any of that no I think you heard judge
Cavanaugh say like many kids that age in
high school and back then the drinking
age was 18 probably you're a little
younger than when that was 18 but I I
was at that same age allowed to drink
and he admits that he drank and did some
things that he looks back on and says
are embarrassing and make you cringe but
that's not what this is about this is
about a very serious allegation we
talked to senator Klobuchar yesterday
who raised these issues and the distance
between the way judge Kavanaugh
describes himself in the way his
colleagues and friends described himself
over this period of time and she said
those are things that really go to
credibility given some of the stories
circulating out there her argument is
that hid the distance between his claims
about himself and these stories about
him go to his credibility do you think
that's not fair game I don't think
that's fair game only because he hasn't
denied any of that I mean he said that
he drank he said that he sometimes drank
more beers than he should no one is no
one is disputing that but that isn't
that is an evidence about what happened
with regard to the canta the charges
that that are being made here but that's
just a sec to follow up on John and be
honest point he did voluntarily share
that he was a virgin in the Fox
interview and now you have a friend
who's tweeting that listen Brett told me
something very differently
so I think for a lot of people it does
raise a credibility issue about him well
III think that was one person many other
people don't don't corroborate that and
so it's you know this is one of the
problems people are selectively taking
certain statements every single person
who was named it was supposed to be at
that party says either the party they
don't know have any recollection of the
party they weren't there or they never
met judge Cavanaugh the same thing about
the allegation at Yale
nobody corroborates that that event
happened she didn't even say when she
was first talking about it that she
remembered that it was Judge Cavanaugh
so I think this is part of the problem
it's so unfair to be pulling out one
statement from one person or another
when you're trying to determine the full
picture of what actually went on here
and from day one judge Kavanagh said he
didn't do this
he never did this and he's never done
anything like it Beth you said it's not
fair game to go into these questions of
the nature of his behavior does that
mean he won't be answering questions
about for example what's on his yearbook
page and and these various stories that
have been told about that his level of
drinking in high school and in college
no of course not here last what he'll
answer whatever questions the committee
decides to ask him all right Beth
Wilkins and thank you so much for
joining us this morning thank you all